der herbst ist jetzt mit großer wucht
gekommen und das verursacht erstmal
enttäuschung und die vier wintermonate
die sind lang november dezember januar
februar und selbst im märz muss man ja
noch den halben märz dazu rechnen bevor
es dann mal richtig für frühling wird
und dieses licht am ende eines tunnels
ist jetzt noch ziemlich weit entfernt
und deshalb verstehe ich schon dass das
schwerfällt und dass man sich damit auch
schwer tut
aber es ist ja nicht sozusagen eine ein
politischer beschluss den wir gefasst
haben soll das ist so etwas wie eine
natur ereignis eine naturkatastrophe mit
der wir umgehen müssen und in der wir
den besten für uns alle vertretbaren weg
finden müssen und wenn jeder sich sagt
mein beitrag dazu dass dieses virus
eingedämmt wird das ist dass ich
verzichte auf kontakte dann weiß man
dass man für die gemeinschaft auch etwas
tut und das kann aus meiner sicht eine
hoffnung und auch ein motiv sein
dafür werde ich jedenfalls und daneben
das wissen das auch fortschritte gemacht
werden bei impfstoffen die nicht sofort
für alle natürlich gehen werden bei der
beiden schutz bestimmter gruppen bei den
testmöglichkeiten und medikamenten und
das ist aber eine sehr sehr schwere zeit
die von uns keiner voraussehen konnte
und die auch sich kein mensch gewünscht
hat also ich kann unmut und unwillen
verstehen muss trotzdem für die
akzeptanz lärm weil wir keine andere
wahl haben mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren